Protesters are back on the streets in Hong
Kong
They are now angry about a proposed extradition
law
Many people fear this law could be used by
the Chinese government as a tool to prosecute
political opponents.
These protests, however might not change anything
So let’s back up and see how all these happened:
As a special administrative region inside
Chinese territory, Hong Kong has a different
legal system, and has long enjoyed freedom
of speech that other parts of China don’t
have.
The protesters are now angry about a proposed
extradition law
If the law passes, political opponents could
be sent to China and face unfair trials
Many people fear this law could be used by
the Chinese government as a tool to prosecute
political opponents.
If the law passes, they might face unfair
trials in China.
we can't give up simply because the government
ignored our demand, because this is our home.
I can see that there are many Hong Kong people
still coming out today and I'm sure there
will be more of us coming out in the coming
couple of weeks/// to show our opposition
to the extradition law."
So why is this law being pushed to a vote?
Because of Hong Kong Chief Executive Carrie
Lam.
Lam might be the leader of Hong Kong, but
she was not democratically elected.
To even get on the list of candidates, she
needed the approval of the Chinese gov.
It’s the Chinese government that allowed
her to become the head of Hong Kong.
The Chief Executive is not elected by the
people, but by a committee of 1200 members.
And to get on the list of candidates, she
needed the approval of the Chinese gov.
Responding to the angry protesters, Lam denies
the Chinese government’s role in the latest
bill proposal
SOT
However, if Lam wants to stay in power, or
even secure a second term, she needs the approval
of the Chinese government.
And China has already expressed eagerness
to pass it
the central government will continue to firmly
support the Hong Kong government in completing
the amendment of the 'two ordinances’ [passing
the extradition law].
For the bill to become law, it still needs
to get more than half of lawmakers’ votes
and it’s probably going to pass.
Because currently, the majority of them have
a pro-China stance
But... there’s still a slim chance for a
surprise outcome.
In 2003, a controversial national security
law sparked demonstrations of over 500,000
people
This led to a pro-Beijing party withdrawing
its support, forcing the government to shelve
the bill
This, however, only happened once.
Now, protesters hope that history will repeat
itself